ااا صباح الخير عليكم معانا قاهره الظلام
زي ما بيلقبوها منه طلع عصام تحدت نفسها
واختارت يعني رياضه المبصرين يمكن ما
بيحققوش فيها اللي هي حققته ومعنا اللواء
اشرف خليفه المدير الفني بنادي فروسيه
الحرس الجمهوري هو مدرب منه هبتدي مع منه
صباح الخير صباح النور ازي حضرتك احكي لي
بقى ولد انت ليه اخترتي رياضه دقيقه كده
همم تخش فيها بالتحدي ده انا مؤمنه جدا
بكل سيدنا عمر بن الخطاب رضي الله عنه
واولادكم السباحه والرمايه وركوب الخير
فانا حابه اتمرن الثلاث الرياض دول انا
بالفعل بدات في الاول في الفرنسيه بس لما
شفت الكرسي والسهم مش الدنيا اكثر
بس باذن الله الفتره الجايه ان شاء الله
هارجع برده للفروسيه ثاني بس انا مجهزه
فيه دلوقت علشان همم حابه اطلع بطوله
انجلترا اللي هتبقى في نصف الجاي باذن
الله وان ان شاء الله ربنا ييسر الحال وفي
بطوله همم وديه الجمعه الجايه ان شاء الله
وكمان في بطوله جمهوريه قبل رمضان باذن
الله طب ازاي بتقدري يعني همم تستغني عن
ال- ال- ال- النظر الى ال- ال- ال- اللي
بتنشيني عليه بتعملي ايه
بصي حضرتك انا مقتنعه جدا ومؤمنه جدا ان
الواحد لما بيحب الحاجه همم حيوان جماد اي
حاجه الحاجه هي كمان بتحبه وبتدي له اللي
هي عايزاه فانا حابه القوس والسهم فاللي
ده بيساعدني ان همم ان انا انشن عن طريق
البن ده باحط يدي الناحيه دي
وبابتدي وانا بارفع القوس وباسحب الوطن
وباضرب والحمد لله بيجيء في الهدف الحمد
لله
البنت ما تضربي قد ايه متدربتي قد ايه انا
في الاول خالص لما بنت الكابتن اشرف
وتعرفت عليه وقلت له على القسم السهم اللي
انا عايزه اتمرن قال لي ما فيش مشكله وفي
شهر هتشوف انت هتضربي ازاي
فالحمد لله بعد شهر فعلا بقيت باضرب كويس
الحمد لله
هتبدئي انا معطله اهو
تفضل معي حضرتك وهي بتتمرن بقى عايزه اعرف
حضرتك
عايزه اعرف من حضرتك ازاي بتقدروا تتدربها
وتوصلها للمستوى ده
صباح الخير انا اللي هو اشرف خليفه المدير
الفني لنادي الفروسيه الحرس الجمهوري ومنه
لاعيبه مجتهده وبتلاقي مراعاه كامله من
نادي الفروسيه الحرس وتحت رعايه الله وليد
مليجي همم نادي نادي بالكامل بي همم بيتم
مراعاه منه همم نفسيا وف وتدريبيه ايه وكل
ده اعدادا احنا هي طبعا دخلت همم دخلت
بطولات كتير فما فيش منها همم او يعني ما
فيش دول همم فاقد البصر في مصر في مصر
وافريقيا وعربوا الشرق اوسط هي الوحيده
فاحنا طالعين ان شاء الله بامر الله دكتور
ابن الهامدي بطوله بتتعمل كل اربع سنين 23
في انجلترا همم من يوم 18 يوم 27 دي
بتتعمل همم الاتحاد همم يعني همم البطوله
دي الفريده من نوعها حدث رياضي غير عادي
بيتم همم استضافه المعاقين دول الاعاقه
البصريه لجميع الرياضات لكن في العالم كله
ما بيبقاش غير مثلا ثمانيه ثمانيه تسعه هم
اللي بيلعبوا الرامات القوس وهمم بيبقوا
يعني الحمد لله ال-
همم الكامله وان شاء الله همم يكمل لها
بخير وتحقق نتيجه كويسه ان شاء الله ان
شاء الله منك
بصوا حضرتك ما فيش حاجه صعبه ابدا على اي
لاعب له هدف وعايز يحققه ليه طارجت وعايز
يوصل له اهم حاجه الثقه بالنفس والثقه
بالمدرب تنفيذ التعليمات اللي بيتقال
عليها وهي منا من من اللاعيبه اللي هم
يعني همم ان هم نائمين جدا بيسمعوا الكلام
اللي بينفذوه ما فيش كومنتات عليها كثير
قوي لان هي اخذت فتره اعداد كبيره اعداد
وبعدين فتره التدريب بتبقى قصيره عكس
المبشرين بياخذوا فتره اعداد بسيطه جدا
لكن التدريب كبير قوي ههه
شكرا لكم صباح الخير عليكم اهو طيب سمر
سؤال سريع يعني بما انه فقدان البصر لا
يعني فقدان البصيره يعني المبصر عندما
يريد ان يصيب في القوس يعني ينظر الى
الهدف مباشره
منه هم عايزين يعرفوا منك في الاستوديو
زمان ونادين ازاي بتقدري تصيب الهدف
بتعملي ايه بايدك بتحسي بايه انك تصيب
الهدف من غير ما تبقى شايفه الدايره
بصي حضرتك انا انا لما لما باركب السهم
بركبه باحطه زي ما زي ما انا بحطه كده
دلوقتي تمام وبعد ما باحطه بيبقى بتبقى
ايدي على البن زي ما قلت لحضرتك كده
[موسيقى]
فبضرب كده فده يعني ثابت ايدي مع مسكه
القوس وشدت الوطن لان الوطن لما بيتشد
القوس بيثقل
فانا لازم ابقى مثبته يدي
وثبات الجسم نفسه ده بيخليني اصيب الهدف
زي ما هو شكرا يا منه وبالتوفيق لك ان شاء
الله هنشوفك في البطوله العالميه في اغسطس
بالتوفيق شكرا
ان شاء الله دائما شكرا